alright guys and this is it this is the
final review for the final Star Wars
movie that exists done after this until
this December Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the Sith
so Star Wars Episode three is the third
Star Wars movie in the Star Wars saga
the final Star Wars movie the Star Wars
prequel trilogy in the last Star Wars
movie that we've actually gotten until
this December when Star Wars Episode
seven comes out it's very confusing if
you're new to the Star Wars universe
point is this is the one where Anakin
turns turncoat becomes a Sith the one
we've been waiting for all our lives
pretty much when this movie came out and
I warn you there are spoilers in this
review for Revenge of the Sith so watch
this video if you have watched Revenge
of the Sith or you just don't care about
spoilers now you've been warned
officially disclaimer is done now it's
no secret I have not been too kind to
the Star Wars prequels I just haven't I
feel they pale in comparison not only to
the original trilogy but really the
standard that movies should be held to
at this point light however this may
shock some people and some people will
be like yeah no duh because it is the
one that is like that I'll tell you
right now I do actually find enjoyment
Revenge of the sets at a perfect movie
no not at all we'll get to that later
the point is I can sit down with this
movie and still enjoy what I'm watching
in this movie war is everywhere the
Clone Wars have been going on for what
you feel like are years Anakin's a lot
more seasoned he has this scar right
here George Lucas when he was asked
about the scars like I don't know he
fell in the bathtub or something I just
thought it looked cool pretty much
explains the mindset George Lucas is
coming from for pretty much the entire
trilogy you do see in this movie obi-wan
and Anakin I feel like they actually
have a relationship in this movie in
Episode two you're looking at that
you're like there is no way that Obi
one's gonna reflect on this brat and be
like and he was a good friend
I don't know he'd be like he was pretty
much a big [ __ ] I I really hope the
apple fell very far from the tree so the
beginning of this movie starts out
Palpatine has been kidnapped by General
Grievous and Count Dooku but ultimately
you're like this Count Dooku know that
Palpatine is Sidious as Grievous no
Palpatine Sidious is it all the ruse I
feel like Dooku knows that Palpatine is
Sidious Oh Grievous has no idea
whatsoever because Grievous is pretty
much useless seriously you look at
Grievous in this movie you're like where
did this dude come from why is he in it
that's one of the things that bogs down
this prequel trilogy every movie has a
new antagonist I feel like it would have
been better if there was one antagonist
you can argue that is Palpatine but
Palpatine is kind of like be
find the scenes you need a guy in the
front lines causing problems like Darth
Maul
Count Dooku General Grievous about that
you just have one guy doing all three of
that [ __ ] always baffle me it was always
abundantly clear that that's one of the
strengths the original trilogy has over
the prequel trilogy this action sequence
in the beginning of this movie it's like
conservatively 20 minutes of the movie I
think it's a round there series a 20
minutes later I was like oh my god we're
still here ultimately so Anakin kills
Count Dooku and that's just what it's
there for like you could have done that
a lot smoother after they clear that
mess up they get back down to chorus
aunt and Padma is like hey Anakin guess
what I'm pregnant she's really funny cuz
ultimately this dude's been off the war
comes back finds out his wife is
pregnant first question out his mouth
probably should have been or so who's
the father and you see more mischief you
know Palpatine's whispering and Anakin's
ear like me a dark side Anakin it's
better and another thing about this
movies that everyone goes on campaigns
where I'm like why did you go there I
mean I wanted to seek a Sheik in a movie
for sure but ultimately you feel like
Yoda was sent to catch Sheik so a we can
seek a Sheik be so Yoda is just out of
the capital when all this [ __ ] goes down
then obi-wan goes to this planet to
chase General Grievous why because when
the [ __ ] goes down obi-wan can't be
there when Anakin turns bad and then
Anakin's turned to the dark side is the
most sudden [ __ ] I've ever seen in a
movie period after Palpatine pretty much
has just screaming Anakin's ear after
subtlety just doesn't work he's like hey
I'm the Sith Lord and I can save padme's
life because I know about Darth Plagueis
the lies and guess what if you piece the
puzzle together yeah I'm the apprentice
I was talking about who killed Anakin
busts out his lightsaber and he's like
I'm turning you over to the Jedi Council
I'm like whoa he's come a long way
that's awesome good job Anakin he goes
and rats him out to mace Windu and mace
when just like okay we're gonna confront
him they'll pop out the lightsabers by
order of the Galactic Senate of the
Republic you're under arrest Chancellor
although when Palpatine comes swinging
at them with this lightsaber you see
that first [ __ ] he kills his head is
turned like this like huh are we
fighting then he just slices him down to
look why were you looking away [ __ ]
maybe Palpatine was using the dark side
on them like Quan Chi like oh okay turn
around Kai
I doubt it it just looked really sloppy
however all this [ __ ] storms building
the best scene in the entire prequel
trilogy happens right here nothing to do
with fighting lightsabers or
confrontation it's when Anakin is
looking out his window and Padme is
looking out her window and just ambient
music really eerie and you can tell
they're both there looking at each other
but they can't see each other it's
really good and right here we see George
Lucas does have a concept that you don't
need words to say something power
so why he felt it necessary to put in
the audio of Vader going know as he
picked up the emperor and returned to
the Jedi to throw him over the thing I
will never know so after mace windu
deflects the force lightning back onto
Sidious his face it burns his face and
makes him look like the Emperor that we
knew from Return of the Jedi which is
funny because I always thought it was
like force corruption because most
things like a look at Star Wars The Old
Republic the more dark side you act the
more dark side force corruption you get
your face so but apparently that's not a
thing so go ahead and turn off for
scripture when you play that game
because it's just not real it's a face
burn but Anakin slices off Mace Windu's
hand the emperor throws him out the
window and there we are and is like oh
what have I done please help me save
padme's life and then evil Sidious is
all like a cheat death there's a power
only one has achieved but if we work
together pretty sure we can figure it
out which makes Anakin slash Vader slash
whoever you supposed to be right now the
biggest idiot in the galaxy seriously
right there he should have been like I'm
pretty sure you told me you know how to
save her life are you saying you don't
now are you saying mace windu just died
and there's no reason for it okay you
show me right now you know how to save
her life otherwise you're going over the
edge and you're joining him I'm going
back to the Jedi Council I'm gonna make
up some [ __ ] story about how you
attacked him and I couldn't save his
life but right after you killed him I I
killed you and my god poor maze as I sit
on the Jedi Council as a Jedi Master
[ __ ] do you show me right now he
looks like
Anakin totally blown away like the
fauces child makes this weird ass face
it's really strange things like I
suppose you'll be known to stop Veda
right and that's part of the frustration
in this movie is that Lucas made
promises that he did not fulfill George
Lucas or Rick McCallum one of those two
dudes was like you will find out why his
name is Darth Vader
and why Jedi learned to come back from
the nether realm of the force in spirit
form you will learn those two things we
learned neither of those two things he
just like dogs they die and I was like
because
rise because nothing nothing at all then
Anakin or Vader's like alright masters
so what do we do now he's like all right
go raid the Jedi Temple and slaughter
children he went from going you're the
Sith Lord I'm turning you over to the
Jedi Council to yeah and why about some
kids why not which is officially the
biggest dick move Vader has ever done in
his life
that we've seen yeah I know he wiped out
Alderaan he aimed a gun at a planet or
you can argue grand moff tarkin did that
but he stood there and just watch planet
gets wiped out yeah that's just plain e
that's genocide and the highest form a
planet's dead but it's something more
personal like when the Joker's like you
know why I use a knife guns are too
quick you can't save her all the little
emotions you feel like it's just a more
evil thing to be able to take your
lightsaber and hack down children it's
funny cuz shortly after my brother and I
saw it he was like let me ask you this
how many Jedi Masters did Vader kill I
was like one killed face one dude he was
like no the Emperor killed mace windu I
was like Jackson please right none he
killed children that's exactly the point
I wanted to see Vader be a badass I
loved that scene where he goes to the
Mustafar and so it's wiping out the
Trade Federation guys cuz no one ever
liked them I was watching Phantom Menace
I was like one of these guys gonna die
now they get to died we get to watch the
massacre so that's all good but really
all he did was kill kids which turns
Vader from a methodical badass villain
into a bully you can be a badass and you
can be evil without killing children DC
Empire Strikes Back when he's in the
cloud city and he stands up and he's got
this nice table with all these crystal
glasses he's like we would be honored if
you would join does she like yeah that
news methodical an awesome you don't
like some dumb [ __ ] who was just
going slaughter children man because on
a dime when he turned to the dark side
after he wasn't on the dark side yeah I
heard the Clone Wars cartoon does fill
in the gaps and he shows how Anakin
slowly turning to the dark side I feel
like you shouldn't need that it should
be like oh I totally buy it in the movie
and if you want to see the Clone Wars
you'll get more of it and that's what
makes it awesome she shouldn't have to
watch the Clone Wars to totally get
everything about Anakin Stern just made
it unrealistic to me I just never bought
that that order 66 scene though he's
like execute order 66 and all the troops
were wiping out the Jedi that's a really
good Saint it's dire it's a sad song
you're like oh man they're getting their
asses killed that scene is an effective
scene moments like that make me look at
this movie and go yeah and enjoy this
movie I can have fun with this movie fun
and like the really dark scene I guess
dr. Anakin is baptised with the blood of
the young padawan children he just goes
to Mustafar wipes out the Trade
Federation guys and just hangs out no
one gets in his head that he has to go
kill Anakin in the prequels in general
this is one of my things that means
because no
was against the original trilogy bear
with me on this [ __ ] Obi one went with
the intent to kill Anakin not bring him
back to the good side granted he killed
children maybe that's why Lucas made him
kill children so he's not redeemable
although the entire saga is about
redeeming Anakin it's weird like when
Padma is like you're gonna kill him
aren't you he's like he's become a very
great threat even tells Yoda is like to
send me to kill the Emperor I cannot
kill Anakin Yodas like yeah just kind of
what needs to happen so we did not go to
moosa' far to confront Anakin to bring
him back to the good side now let's look
at the original trilogy Luke went to
Vader he told lay he's like I can bring
him back to the good side they're still
good in him I felt it through everything
the original trilogy taught us is how a
Jedi should be thinking you know go in
there with your lightsaber lit we're
looking for a fight going hey I'm gonna
kill you but obi-wan in Revenge of the
Sith went to kill Anakin it must have
farm granted in Return of the Jedi he
even told Luke he's like he's more
machine now than man twisted and evil so
he obviously looked like he didn't have
any faith in him but I'd like to think
that twenty-something years after the
fact old obi-wan has that mindset
because 20-something years before he
tried to bring him to the good side that
didn't work out and then they got into a
fight but instead after he's like he's
my machine now than man twisted and evil
Luke and just be like cool did you try
you try to bring him back to the good
side well no well shut up do not a Jedi
yet okay you can't lecture me more than
that that's just one situation but if
you look at the overall theme of the
trilogy's and you take them separately
in the original trilogy the person who
struck their lightsaber first when going
into a fight they were the ones making
the bad decision obi-wan fights Vader in
the original Star Wars Vader's
lightsabers lit obi-wan light is because
he knows the fights coming but Vader had
it lit Vader picked the fight Luke
confronts Vader in the Cloud City Luke
strikes his lightsaber then Vader
strikes his lightsaber let's not say
Vader's good it just shows that Luke is
hasting he's not ready to be a Jedi
because he's making the wrong decisions
he's looking for a fight first I can
think about when yo does like leave your
weapons you won't need him and he goes
into the cave and he sees Vader Luke
strikes his lightsaber first then the
fake Vader does and that's why Luke
failed Return of the Jedi Luke does make
the wrong decision but it addresses the
wrong decision the Emperor's taunting
Luke then Luke takes the lightsaber and
tries to kill him and the Emperor starts
laughing cuz he's like yeah those are
the wrong decisions we're looking for
that's what bad guys do that is the Jedi
lesson that we got for an entire trilogy
of movies show your Jedi quality so now
you take a look
the prequels I think phantomon has
headed alright because Darth Maul struck
his lightsaber and then qui-gon and
obi-wan danced all right I'll give
Phantom Menace that but Attack of the
Clones mace Windu and Yoda tell obi-wan
to go bring Jango Fett back to Coruscant
so they can question him he goes out
there Jango Fett turns around and
obi-wan just whips out his lightsaber
failed the test
the fight between obi-wan Anakin and
Count Dooku what we wanted Anakin run
into the hangar their lightsabers are
lit Dooku just turns around like hi I'm
gone they failed the test Revenge of the
Sith has so many lightsaber scenes I'm
gonna go ahead and like narrow it down
to obi-wan and Anakin fight obi-wan says
only a Sith deals in absolutes even
though Yoda said do or do not there is
no try
obi-wan strikes his lightsaber and
Anakin says you will try then he strikes
his and flips back and they start
fighting Obi one failed that test said
even when Yoda's confront the emperor he
goes if so powerful you are why fully
[ __ ] Yoda failed that test but we
already established Yoda as a set for
the deals in absolutes point is that's
just a huge message and a subtlety
throughout the original trilogy so it's
just kind of disregarded in the prequels
stuff like that irritates me it feels
like it's two completely separate
universes at that point everyone starts
fighting an obi-wan and Anakin fights
pretty sweet not gonna lie I mean yeah
it's really clean you're like that is
completely choreographed it look like
they're dancing I don't give a [ __ ] it
looked cool I like going through the
hallways lightsabers hitting walls
there's even a scene where they like
clash lightsabers and start using the
force that was really cool I mean the
fight I loved it I even liked Yoda in
the Emperor fighting you know I don't
like Yoda with a stupid lifesaver
because I think it's stupid cuz Yoda
doesn't need a lifesaver because he's
just badass anyway but I enjoy that
fight too John Williams music queues up
and I'm just I'm having a good time with
this [ __ ] but then the fight goes on for
way too long you shouldn't be bored in a
fight if I should just not bore you but
if I can go on for so long that you
start checking your watch you're like
alright man this can end we get the
point there's conflict here I know
exactly the moment it happens after
Anakin obi-wan do that clash and the
lava shoots up in that whole thing
breaks and goes into the lava and they
start climbing up and whacking at each
other and at that point I'm bored from
there till the end just drags on you're
like let's just wrap this up and
everyone has the high ground slices off
Anakin's legs and arm and you just start
sliding down other ones like you were
the chosen one Anika's like I hate you
however he does say a key phrase here he
says you were my brother Anakin I loved
you wait a minute but a Jedi I shall not
know anger nor hatred nor love so Obi
Wan's
in the rules to because you loved Anakin
attachments forbidden love is forbidden
but obi-wan was attached to Anakin and
loved him they're talking about sex
because that's different should it be a
Jedi shall not know anger nor hatred nor
sex you can have sex without love and
you can have love without sex so they
need love and sex well it's like this or
why I'm like not just this bad writing
which is why when Padme dies of a stupid
broken heart it's just bad writing and
anyone who's talked about Revenge of the
Sith even if they love the movie they
like that that was a dumbass to have a
broken heart that's stupid and there's a
theory out there I know where people are
like the Emperor killed Padme with the
force he's really super secret thing
however it's been established that
George Lucas is not good at writing and
he's not good at subtlety doing that
would require good writing and subtlety
I mean this movie in the script still
has that shitty Shakespearean dialogue
between Anakin and Padme is not in there
a lot but it's still in there like when
she was like I just want to go back to
the fields of Naboo when there was
nothing but our love so in your face
like when Padma is like Anakin you're
breaking my heart like you obviously you
have a broken heart Ryung and [ __ ] you
don't want to turn to the dark side
people can assess that your heart is
breaking you don't have to say you're
breaking my heart point being George
Lucas is not subtle in his script
writing each has to throw things in your
face so if someone's asking me if I
think George Lucas is clever enough to
concoct this deeper meaning hidden
message about the Emperor killing Padme
with the force now I would say her dying
of a broken hearts just bad
screenwriting because that's where the
evidence points to sometimes the
simplest answer is the correct answer
and the simplest answer is it's just bad
writing if he disagree awesome you
should do a video about that this is
just my take on it when Anakin Zahl
Darth Vader he's all Frankenstein he
busts out like his Frankenstein he goes
no I was like they just have him
irritated and raised maybe have
everything crumble around him and then
but not have him scream no he's having
turns the Emperor would be like there's
nothing left there is only the Empire
the Emperor can have that shit-eating
grin is like yeah let's look go build a
Death Star spend 20 years doing it guys
in the end Revenge of the Sith has
problems for sure but it does have
enjoyment also might feel like I bitched
about this movie a lot but ultimately I
can still sit down and enjoy the movie
or at least have the movie playing in
ambiance you know like I'm playing Star
Wars The Old Republic I'm like a Revenge
of the Sith is right there the Anakin
Obi one fight that ultimately the entire
prequel trilogy is coming down to is
pretty cool until it starts boring you I
wish it was a more believable turn
for Anakin to turn into Darth Vader and
I wish it was a better representation of
how badass Vader in his prime would have
been his negatives it has positives I
don't buy everything I don't believe
everything but the movie does allow me
to have fun while I'm watching and I'll
certainly say Revenge of the Sith it's a
pretty good time no alcohol required all
right guys so Revenge of the Sith have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite Star Wars movie
of all time or hell Star Wars book Canon
not never Timothy Zahn fans are still
out there and they're pissed
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more